let's take the sale if we did our job I
would hope that doesn't mess you did you
get from it's about
all right Mike let's get you guys in
there thank you x you see people thought
of you he did a show that they're ready
they're like what are those guys doing
up there weird see a movie printed out
of my home printer black and white why I
do feel you're trying to grab attention
and I remember walking into DM to the
lobby of the hotel there is huge amazing
beautiful professionally printed Stevie
Wonder show poster and you know like the
incredible postcards and he's mastered
our labels created thing you see long
time just me and I was like I was like
but I was all scared oh my god I one out
of the state no I'm gonna make traveled
here and then I met these guys and they
were so welcoming you know they were
really interested in my film one and
they were very illegal about the whole
thing and I saw the film and I really
love this film it's gotta grow you know
unique vision it's really movin it's
witty it's gorgeous dark gotta work on
policy and you know Stevens variable job
sharp the most radical just to see our
fantastic i didn't know how the whole
thing off but but it's just a really
it's a really great true independent
film and I was glad as you know
and has fear really a chair she's
independent film so
but just slow down the film forever but
we've got picked a lot until time kind
of ran out I guess two years Chris had a
question for Chris knows anything like
really embarrassing that you like yeah
yeah no I mean there got to be a certain
point where you just had to trust Mike
and it's hard to watch it sometimes but
you know I'm very proud of the end
result and then I believed in the script
so I mean I wouldn't have done it if I
didn't think I couldn't look at it but I
still can't look at it it's very hard
truth he did you did game like how much
like 40 pounds oh there's money 556
having 50 pounds see that's cool but you
know it's like as far as something I'm
excited but it seems like the gap just
being bridge
the Indies hold on I gotta back up to
eat you all in it all right there we go
perfect boom